[APPLAUSE] >> NOW THE RESULT.
I, SIR GRAHAM BRADY FOR THE
RETURNING OFFICER FOR THE
CONSERVATIVE LEADERSHIP
ELECTION, DECLARED THE COASTAL
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE VOTERS WAS
172, 000, 437.
THE TURNOUT IN THE ELECTION WAS
82.6%, AND THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
VOTES REJECTED WAS 654.
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF VALID VOTES
GIVE EACH CANDIDATE WAS AS
FOLLOWS: RISHI SUNAK, 60, 399,
LIZ TRUSS 81,000 AND 326.
BEFORE I GIVE NOTICE THAT LIZ
TRUSS IS ELECTED AS LEADER OF
THE CONSERVATIVE AND UNIONIST
PARTY.
LIZ, COME UP HERE.
[APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE] >> THANK YOU, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WOLF THANK YOU, SIR GRAHAM.
IT IS AN HONOR TO BE ELECTED AS
LEADER OF THE CONSERVATIVE
UNIONIST PARTY.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE 1922
COMMITTEE, THE PARTY CHAIRMAN,
AND THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY FOR
ORGANIZING ONE OF THE LONGEST
JOB INTERVIEWS IN HISTORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
FAMILY, MY FRIENDS, AND MY
POLITICAL COLLEAGUES AND ALL OF
THOSE WHO HELPED ON THIS
CAMPAIGN.
I AM INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT.
I'D LIKE TO PAY TRIBUTE TO MY
FELLOW CANDIDATES PARTICULARLY
RISHI SUNAK.
IT'S BEEN A HARD FOUGHT
CAMPAIGN, AND I THINK WE HAVE
SHOWN THE DEPTH OF TALENT IN
OUR CONSERVATIVE PARTY.
[APPLAUSE] THEY ALSO WANT TO
THINK OUR OUTGOING LEADER, MY
FRIEND, BORIS JOHNSON.
BORIS, YOU GOT BREXIT DONE.
YOU CRUSHED JEREMY CORBYN.
YOU ROLLED OUT THE VACCINE, AND
YOU STOOD UP TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
YOU ARE ADMIRED FROM KYIV TO
CARLISLE.
[APPLAUSE] FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES, THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING YOUR FAITH IN ME TO
LEAD OUR GREAT CONSERVATIVE
PARTY, THE GREATEST POLITICAL
PARTY ON EARTH.
[APPLAUSE] I KNOW, I KNOW THAT
OUR BELIEFS RESONATE WITH THE
BRITISH PEOPLE.
OUR BELIEFS AND FREEDOM, AND
THE ABILITY TO CONTROL YOUR OWN
LIFE, IN LOW TAXES, IN PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I KNOW THAT IS WHY PEOPLE
VOTED FOR US IN SUCH NUMBERS IN
2019.
AS YOUR PARTY LEADER, I INTEND
TO DELIVER WHAT WE PROMISED
THOSE VOTERS RIGHT ACROSS OUR
GREAT COUNTRY.
DURING THIS
LEADERSHIP CAMPAIGN, I
CAMPAIGNED AS A CONSERVATIVE
AND I WILL GOVERN AS A
CONSERVATIVE.
[APPLAUSE] AND MY FRIENDS, WE
NEED TO SHOW THAT WE WILL
DELIVER OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
I WILL DELIVER A BOLD PLAN TO
CUT TAXES AND GROW OUR ECONOMY.
I WILL DELIVER ON THE ENERGY
CRISIS DEALING WITH PEOPLES
ENERGY BILLS, BUT ALSO DEALING
WITH THE LONG TERM ISSUES WE
HAVE ON ENERGY SUPPLY.
[APPLAUSE] AND I WILL DELIVER
ON THE NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE.
BUT WE ALL WILL DELIVER FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND I WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE USE ALL OF THE
FANTASTIC TALENTS OF THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY AND ARE
BRILLIANT MEMBERS OF PARLIAMENT
AND ARE FANTASTIC COUNSELORS
AND ARE MS IS, OUR MS PIECE,
ALL OF OUR COUNSELORS AND
ACTIVISTS IN MEMBERS ALL ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY BECAUSE MY FRIENDS,
I KNOW THAT WE WILL DELIVER, WE
WILL DELIVER, WE WILL DELIVER.
AND WE --
[APPLAUSE] AND WE WILL DELIVER
A GREAT VICTORY FOR THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY IN 2024.
THANK, YOU THANK YOU LE PEN.
[APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE] THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE] >> LIZ TRUSS, THE
PRIME MINISTER DESIGNATE HERE
IN THE UNITED KINGDOM.
SHE DOES IMMEDIATELY BECOME
PRIME MINISTER, BUT SHE IS
TAKING OVER FROM BORIS JOHNSON
IN TEN DOWNING STREET FORMERLY
TOMORROW WHEN SHE VISITS THE
QUEEN, THAT WILL HAPPEN
TOMORROW, BUT EFFECTIVELY, FROM
NOW, SHE WILL BE TAKING CHARGE
A KEY POLICY, 10 DOWNING STREET,
AND TAKING PART OF THE HANDOVER
AND THAT PRESUMES AT THE FORMER
FOREIGN SECRETARY, NOT A HUGELY
WELL-KNOWN FIGURE IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM, BUT VERY WELL-KNOWN IN
WESTMINSTER, THE LONGEST
SERVING CABINET MEMBER AND THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY, SOMEONE WHO
KNOWS WESTMINSTER EXTREMELY
WELL AND SHE CAMPAIGNED TO
CONSERVATIVE PARTY VOTERS ON
LOWER TAXES AND PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, AND SHE WON
WITH THAT MESSAGE AGAINST
RICHIE SUNAK WHO WAS THE
FINANCE MINISTER, WHO NOW
CONTINUES AS THE MEMBER OF
PARLIAMENT.
LET'S SPEAK TO NICK, WHO WAS
ALSO DIGESTING THAT POLICY.
BUT NICK, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
THE SPEECH ON HOW SHE WILL
CARRY THINGS FORWARD?
>> YES, LOW TAX, GROW BUSINESS,
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY,
CONSERVATIVE VALUES AS SHE SAID
SHE CAMPAIGNED ON, AND THIS IS
THE WAY THAT SHE IS GOING TO
RUN THE COUNTRY ON THOSE SAME
CONSERVATIVE VALUES.
I WAS STRUCK ACTUALLY BY A
COUPLE THINGS THAT SHE SAID.
ONE BIG TAKEAWAY IS THAT SHE
WOULD DELIVER ON THIS BASIS A
CONSERVATIVE VICTORY AND THE
NEXT GENERAL ELECTION IN 2024.
VERY CLEARLY SIGNALING THERE
WILL NOT BE ANOTHER ELECTION,
OR SHE CERTAINLY DOESN'T PLAN
AN ELECTION THIS YEAR OR NEXT
YEAR, AND SHE WILL GO THE FULL
FIVE YEAR TERM.
BORIS JOHNSON WON THAT
RESOUNDING VICTORY BACK IN
DECEMBER OF 2019.
AND THE OTHER THING, I THOUGHT
IT WAS KIND OF INTERESTING, BUT
ALSO KIND OF TELLING OF ONE OF
THE HUGE CHALLENGES THAT SHE
HAS COMING DOWN THE ROAD AHEAD
OF HER, THAT WHEN SHE SPOKE
WITH BORIS JOHNSON'S POPULARITY
RUNNING ALL THE WAY FROM KYIV
IN UKRAINE OF OIL WHERE HE IS
VERY POPULAR, THE UK IS VERY
POPULAR FOR THE SUPPORT IS
GIVEN TO THE UKRAINIANS, ALL
THE WAY TO CARLISLE.
WHILE PICK CARLISLE?
THAT'S A BORDER TOWN IN THE
NORTH OF ENGLAND ON THE BORDER
WITH SCOTLAND.
IT RATHER UNDERLINES THE FACT
THAT THE CONSERVATIVE PARTY IS
NOT POPULAR IN SCOTLAND, AND AT
THE SCOTTISH NATIONAL PARTY ARE
GIRDING THEMSELVES TO HAVE
ANOTHER SCOTTISH INDEPENDENCE
REFERENDUM.
THAT OF COURSE WILL BE A BIG
CHALLENGE FOR LIZ TRUSS.
SHE SPOKE WITH THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE PARTY ACROSS THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
AND I DO THINK THAT THIS ISSUE
OF SCOTLAND IS ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT WILL VERY FIRMLY
PRESENT ITSELF TO HER AS IT WAS
TO PORTIONS OF THE CALL FOR
INDEPENDENTS IN SCOTLAND, AND
HOW SHE HANDLES THE MOVES OVER
HANDLING THE HIGH AND RISING
COST OF ENERGY AND HOW THAT IT
WILL IMPACT SCOTLAND, AND ALL
OF THESE ARE GOING TO BE THE
BIG TEST OF HER.